طيب في نهايه احتفالنا بيوم المراه
العالمي اسمحوا لنا بتفاعلكم واحنا على
فكره يعني فريق نسائي بامتياز انه نقول
كلمه يعني واقفه في حلولنا مؤخرا نقصد
يعني في اخر كم سنه صايرين نسمع اصوات
رجاليه كثير بتعترض على الاحتفالات بيوم
المراه وشايفه انه يعني اوفر مره الموضوع
وانه لين نحتفل بالمراه وما نحتفل بالرجل
وبيلومه حتى علينا في الاعلام انه ما
بنتكلم عن الرجال جالسين بس نحتفي بالمراه
طيب لكل الرجال من هؤلاء بنقول انه يا
جماعه ترى مو مشكلتنا انه انتم ما
بتحتفلوا بيومكم العالمي وما بتعملوا
احتفاليات ومناسبات وايفنتات ترى لكم يوم
عالمي ابشركم 19 نوفمبر بس اذا انتم مو
عارفين عنه ما بتحتفلوا فيه احنا ايش نسوي
ما نحتفل بنفسنا الى ان تحتفلوا بنفسكم
انتم اهو احنا الان بلغناكم للي ما يعرف
ترى يومكم العالم يا رجال في 19 نوفمبر
اعملوا احتفاليات اشتغلوا عليه خلوا الامم
المتحده تعترف فيه واحنا وعد علينا نتكلم
عنه ونغطي او يمكن لا